Ce sketch vous est proposé
en audiodescription.
Un homme attend dans un café.
Un autre homme arrive,
cela fait deux hommes.
Salut mec.
Une serveuse
s'approche des deux hommes.
Bonjour.
Bonjour,
je vais prendre un déca.
Euh...
Deux, s'il vous plait.
Ils commandent de façon
directive à la serveuse.
Ça va toi sinon ?
Oui, ouais ouais.
J'étais à Pôle Emploi ce matin,
deux heures trente de queue mon gars !
Et le gars qui était à l'accueil
parce qu'il y a juste un guichet,
ressemblait à Pascal Légitimus.
Et donc ?
Et donc euh, voilà,
j'avais beaucoup de temps à perdre,
et j'ai couché avec ton petit frère...
Le truc...
Vraiment l'anecdote quoi !
L'homme regarde
à présent les fesses du jeune serveur.
Tu m'écoutes quand je te parle ?
Mais pas du tout !
Et bah super !
Nan c'est pas ça, je regardais pas ses fesses,
c'est juste que j'ai faim !
Pardon, l'homme ne regardait
pas ses fesses.
Voilà, merci !
Car il est probablement homophobe.
HEIN ?
PUTAIN !
La gentille serveuse
renverse son café sur l'homme
qui se met à l'insulter
car il se croit supérieur.
Comment ?
Excusez-moi,
je vais tout nettoyer...
Vous en faites pas,
ça arrive à tout le monde, y'a pas de souci.
Je suis vraiment désolée...
L'homme n'essuie
même pas lui-même sa chemise
parce qu'il pense
que c'est à une femme de le faire.
Du coup nan,
ça va je vais le faire.
De mieux en mieux,
maintenant l'homme refuse
avec condescendance l'aide de la femme.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Et voilà, les hommes
se liguent à présent contre la femme,
un réflexe ancestral
de mâle dominant, c'est classique !
Non, c'est juste
que cette... chère Madame...
- hautain !
Cette jolie demoiselle...
- harcèlement sexuel !
Cette jeune femme...
- pédophile !
Cette serveuse...
- vous pouvez directement
dire "esclave" hein !
Personne du sexe féminin...
- sexiste !
Cet humain possédant des règles...
- transphobe !
Ce mammifère... issu...
d'une évolution de plusieurs milliards d'années
appartenant à la race humaine...
- trop long, beaucoup trop long.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Ce bordel, comme tu dis,
c'est que la personne
qui est juste à côté de toi
et que tu paies moins
bien qu'un homme, au passage,
est complètement désorientée,
obligée de faire un
boulot de merde qu'elle déteste !
Nan mais attendez,
n'importe quoi, c'est mon oncle,
il m'a filé un stage dans son bistrot
pour approfondir mon école hôtelière.
Et ça c'est nous deux,
deux semaines après sa naissance.
Super intéressant !
Mais mettons fin
à cette société
patriarcale !
Tant qu'on y est, je veux pas dire,
mais y'a aucun noir dans le sketch ?
Enfin on va pas mettre
un noir juste pour mettre un noir,
ce serait
encore plus con et raciste...
Par contre
pour les juifs on dit rien ?
Bonjour.
Ouais,
alors ça c'est pas voulu, hein.
Bah si,
c'est écrit page 6 !
Ta gueule.
Ah oui donc
on insulte les chinois là y'a pas de problème ?
Mais tu n'es PAS chinois !
Raciste...
Donc, ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on va se détendre,
on va se calmer et passer une bonne après-midi...
UN bon après-midi.
Si je puis me permettre, on dit "un bon après-midi"
car l'emploi du masculin est beaucoup plus correct.
OK !
Ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va trouver
quelque chose qui va mettre tout le monde d'accord...
Voilà, super, un losange !
Ceci est un losange,
c'est mathématique !
On est d'accord ?
Alors oui,
mais c'est aussi un carré !
En effet, tous les carrés, sont des losanges,
mais tous les losanges, ne sont pas des carrés !
Alors, soyez gentils,
pas d'amalgame !
Bon, ce que je propose
pour mettre tout le monde d'accord,
on va refaire ce sketch
en essayant de ne blesser personne.
Ok ?
Ouais !
Ça vous va ?
CHUT !
Euh... non mais là je...
je vais rien dire...